sometime in the 11th century a peasant
slipped away from the village in Europe
to which he was bound for life
his family was required to work the soil
for the local Lord and had done so for
centuries longer than anyone could
remember
this peasant however wanted something
more something new as soon as the Great
Gate of a local Town opened he entered
now he only had to live in the town for
a year and a day
hiding from the Lord's men who might
look for him and he would be forever
free
he would no longer be a serf but a
townsman free to make his choices
while great events like Crusades Wars
and dynastic changes dominated the
Chronicles the headlines of the day
the future of Western Society was being
formed in these commercial towns that
were growing up during the high Middle
Ages
in this lecture I will look at Western
Europe and West Africa where trade
networks transformed society and culture
I will begin in Western Europe whereby
the 11th century commercial towns began
to appear almost everywhere
during the Early Middle Ages after the
fall of the Western Roman Empire the few
towns in the west were primarily
administrative centers that's where a
bishop might live as he presided over
the church's business
after the year 1000 with the population
growth and an increased desire for trade
more cities grew up to satisfy
commercial needs
but the growth of these cities raised an
unusual problem in the rural West
how to organize and govern them
during the Early Middle Ages the feudal
system had developed to support armies
of mounted Knights supported by serfs
bound to the soil
Lords and Kings offered land in exchange
for military service and the system
worked pretty well to field and support
armies
in the 11th century a bishop summarized
the right order of society that this
feudal system represented he wrote from
the beginning mankind has been divided
into three parts men of Prayer
farmers and Men of War
this simple three-part understanding of
the correct order of society
mentioned nothing of towns or merchants
or artisans
unlike the East which maintained a long
tradition of urban Society the West had
to reinvent it
let's first look at the founding of
commercial towns themselves
groups of merchants or lower nobility
who wanted to found a town would obtain
a charter from the Lord on Whose lands
the town stood
these Charters granted townspeople
freedom from the labor obligations that
bound The Peasants who lived on the land
a lord could not come to town to demand
free men come to work to build a road or
a castle
or command women to come help sheer
sheep or bake bread
these Charters also guaranteed
protection from unreasonable taxation
some towns were even able to gain the
right to run their own Law Courts free
from Royal law
in exchange for these rights the Lord
received money and ongoing payments from
the increasingly prosperous towns
it is this kind of freedom from the
feudal system that Drew some peasants
and Artisans to escape for a year and a
day to live an urban life
these towns occupied a violent world so
residents first build walls to protect
themselves
the great Gates were closed at night
preventing anyone from entering
these walls Define the space of a city
so thoroughly that the earliest
definition of a town in a 16th century
dictionary claimed they were residential
areas surrounded by walls
of course the freedom within the walls
that attracted so many didn't mean
Anarchy talents had to develop ways to
govern themselves the townspeople joined
together in sworn Mutual Aid and
protection associations called communes
this word comes from the same root as
the 19th century term communism both
meaning from the community
the communes elected their own officials
regulated taxation within the town and
generally provided Safety and Security
within the walls
they were not Democratic for people
accepted it as natural that rich
citizens would govern the town so
Merchants were disproportionately
represented as leaders
this in turn stimulated long distance
trade
Tradesmen within the towns also
developed ways to regulate the trade and
Manufacturing within the walls of the
town
they formed guilds Collective
organizations of Tradesmen to establish
rules for their trade
for example there were Guilds of gold
work shoemaking bread baking and so
forth they decided who could work in the
trade they regulated the quality of the
work and set prices
since women usually outnumbered men in
the cities they participated in the
guilds and families arranged marriages
to retain control of Commerce
widows ran businesses and took their
husbands places in a business
boys and girls served as apprentices in
the shops until they learned the trade
then they could work as a paid employee
called a journeyman under the guidance
of a guild member
finally a journeyman had to present a
sample of their best work whether a fine
pair of shoes or an intricate piece of
jewelry to the guild Masters if this
masterpiece was found worthy the
journeyman was promoted to a full member
of The Guild
a master
notice that there is nothing of free
enterprise here prices and quality were
set and even the numbers of Tradesmen
were established
if the guild decided there were too many
artisans in a given field a new master
had to leave the town to find a place in
another town
if a worker were skilled he might find a
town that needed Bakers or goldsmiths an
unskilled worker like the surf with whom
I began this lecture might work as an
apprentice until he was trained was not
easy but an age when Mobility upward and
Geographic was frowned upon this was a
breath of fresh air
the layout of the towns was also set by
the guilds and the commune most towns
grew up organically with no planned grid
as we saw in the Chinese cities instead
as we can see in the layout of old parts
of European cities the streets followed
a winding pattern with no plan
all the members of One Guild stayed on
one street The Butcher Street the
Goldsmith Street
center of the city always included a
church the larger cities proudly sported
a cathedral home of the bishop and the
center of town
with the expanding economy certain
demographics began to shift to the
Forefront of urban life
one such group was the Jewish population
ever since the time of the Roman Empire
many medieval towns had a significant
population of Jews acting as Merchants
Artisans and in most jobs in the city
traditionally Jews had taken a
particularly strong role in early
Banking and there were a couple of
reasons for this
on the one hand in many kingdoms like
England Jews were forbidden to own land
which was the traditional place people
invested their money
there were no real Banks even Kings kept
their National Treasury and boxes stored
in their castles
since Jews could not own land they held
their profits in cash which they could
lend
a second reason Jews entered money
lending was that Christians were
forbidden to charge interest on money
that they lent it was considered a sin
to make money on time since time
belonged to God
after all interest is the cost of money
over time
since Jews had no such prohibition
Christians came to Jews to borrow money
when Richard the lionhearted was held
for ransom after his Crusade his mother
Eleanor of Aquitaine raised the money by
borrowing from her Jewish subjects
most of the time in the Middle Ages Jews
and Christians co-existed as they built
the new growing Urban centers in the
West
we have Charters and other records that
show the often close relationship
between urban Jews and the Lords of the
land for example in the late 11th
century we have a charter granted by a
bishop to Jews who were willing to
settle in the German Town of spire
the bishop wrote that he thought it
would greatly add to spire's honor if I
should establish some Jews in it
he offered them special trading
concessions in return for their
settlement
in another example
at the beginning of the 13th century
King Henry III of England issued a
special Charter of protection for the
Jews
but these relationships didn't mean that
there was never trouble against the Jews
in 1290 for example King Edward the
first of England expelled all the Jews
from England allowing them to take their
valuables with them
but leaving their uncollected debts
behind
Urban Christians and Jews depended on
each other in an uneasy coexistence
throughout most of the Middle Ages
the development of these towns provided
a vehicle for Commerce to grow for both
Christians and Jews
now let's look at the long distance
trade patterns that fed the wealth of
these cities
by the 11th century Europe had two major
trading zones the first and oldest was
centered on Northern Italy which became
a significant source for the luxury
goods coming from the East Venice Pisa
and Genoa were their substantial fleets
took the lead
as early as 1082 the venetians had
received Charters giving them free trade
in Byzantine Waters and Pisa and Genoa
negotiated similar treaties with Muslim
rulers that opened new markets the
Italian fleets of this Southern trade
zone brought the traditional silks and
spices passing through the great Muslim
bazaars in Baghdad but they also traded
in North Africa where as we will see new
trade routes brought goods North from
sub-Saharan West Africa
by the 11th century a new northern trade
zone had emerged that brought the north
into the prosperous Trade Network but
also developed a new way of organizing
urban life
the northern Zone was centered on the
Baltic and the North Sea
this Northern Region had a number of
items that were much in demand
the first pillar of this trade was the
demand for dried cod fish
the large Cod is a cold water fish and
Scandinavian fishermen brought their
catch to shore where it was dried and
salted this huge bottom feeding fish had
flesh that had almost no fat
fat resists salt so oily fish have to be
packed in barrels Cod on the other hand
can be air dried salted and simply
stacked
then it would last a long time and could
be exported all over
new DNA studies of fish bones show that
Baltic Cod was consumed all over Europe
and even into the Middle East
fish were also supplemented by more
luxury goods from the north Amber Furs
hunting Hawks and even precious Lumber
were exported
perhaps the most influential trade in
this Northern Zone was the World Trade
we have seen that fine breeds of sheep
have been brought into England from
Spain and North Africa
by the 11th century English landlords
converted portions of their lands to
sheep raising
they exported the raw wool to cities and
Flanders particularly Bruges and Ghent
where the wool was spun into fine cloth
for export
since the early 14th century the Speaker
of the House of Lords in London has been
sitting on a wool sack as a reminder of
wool as the source of England's wealth
this Northern zone of trade was
dominated by cities and beginning in the
late 12th century some of these Northern
cities joined together to guard each
other against raids by Pirates and to
coordinate trading efforts
the first aligned cities probably began
in lubic in Northern Germany but the
alliance extended from London all the
way to northgarode and Russia by the
13th century this Alliance was
formalized by a series of Charters that
was called The Hanseatic League Hansa
means Guild in medieval German and the
cities were dominated by German
merchants
at its height the Hanseatic League
included many cities over time these
range from 20 to 200 and this group The
transcended National boundaries remained
powerful until the 16th century when the
rise of national monarchies separated
this Alliance
throughout the high and late Middle Ages
however the Hanseatic League brought
prosperity to the north
Travelers today to Bergen can still see
the great warehouses that stored the
goods and the Old Town features a large
carving of a cod fish which brought so
much wealth to the north
the markets still sell the dried salted
cod which takes a skilled cook to
prepare
as we can see by the organization of the
Hanseatic League the growth of
commercial urban life
had nothing to do with the land of
nobility who were responsible for
fielding armies however early in the
12th century the French count of
champagne figured out how to make a
profit from this widening web of trade
he granted charters for various towns
and Champaign to organize and host fairs
that would periodically bring Merchants
from both zones of trade together
the count provided the space for the
fares set up booths arrange for police
to keep order and provided money
changers to facilitate trade
each day the fair featured a different
product from wool to cloth to fish Etc
and the count collected a sales tax
from all the transactions that were made
we are so used to having entertainment
available to us all the time it's hard
to imagine how exciting these fares
would be there were jugglers and
musicians and people heard music and
poetry from far regions there were games
and snacks available at the booths that
were hastily erected in a great field
we can get a sense of the excitement of
the fairs through Modern Recreations of
these events in medieval fairs that are
held in many cities today
at these fairs people could also see
goods from afar
silks from the East and exotic animal
pelts from sub-Saharan Africa by way of
Italian Merchants landing at North
African ports
in these great Mercantile trade shows it
became clear that the world Beyond
Europe was never very far away
now I will turn to West Africa where a
new Empire had grown up to become a
power in the 12th century
while the Middle East was frequently a
region of warfare between Crusaders and
the invasions of various Turkish tribes
Islam spread peacefully and without much
notice in the west into sub-Saharan
Africa
during the 9th and 10th centuries Berber
Muslim Traders from the north brought
Islam into the region and tribes in the
South converted slowly from their
traditional religions
such slow conversions allowed for some
traditional practices to become
associated with Muslim practices and a
syncretic form of Islam appeared in
Africa
we have seen that female genital
mutilation was one traditional African
practice that became associated with
Islam but there were others
a very religious Muslim traveler to Mali
in the 14th century commented on
differing Muslim practices in the court
of a particularly Pious Malian emperor
The Traveler IBN batuta approved of the
education that required people to learn
the Quran by heart but he was shocked by
some bad practices he wrote that women
servants slave girls and young daughters
appear naked before people exposing
their genitals women who come before the
sultan are naked and unveiled and so are
his daughters
in addition to what he perceived as
lack's behavior of women even batuta
also reprimanded these African Muslims
for their dietary practices
instead of keeping Halal rules of
cleanliness he claimed the Africans eat
carrion dogs and donkeys
as all religions discovered even in this
age of Faith religious practices are
never uniform they are always informed
by local cultural practices
but in spite of even batuta's complaints
by the early 13th century Mali was
indeed a devout Islamic State
its attachment to Islam made the Mali
Empire a significant trading partner to
North Africa the Middle East and even
into Europe
this Empire emerged in 1235 and lasted
throughout the Middle Ages and in time
all of Eurasia became acutely aware of
the wealth and power of West Africa
as we have seen everywhere from China to
Western Europe the prosperity of the
high Middle Ages began with Agriculture
and a relative piece that allowed for
trade the same was true for the Mali
Empire
the conquest of the rulers of Mali
provided internal peace and travelers in
the 14th century commented on how goods
and Traders could pass through these
lands with no fear of Bandits or other
problems
mali's agricultural produce was helped
in part by the climatic warm period of
the high Middle Ages
that let the Vikings explore to North
America
in Africa this climate shift brought dry
weather that caused people to move from
the borders of the Sahara an area called
the Sahel to the great Savannahs to the
South
the Sahel is a semi-arid zone that
extends all across Africa
separating the desert from the south
this Zone was inhabited by semi-nomadic
people who let flocks of hearty goats
and sheep browse along the scrub then as
now this border region was susceptible
to periodic droughts that drove people
South
but the Border was always important to
facilitate the trade across the Sahara
during the warm period many people of
the Sahel moved South but the rulers of
Mali continued to control this
Borderland
during the Mali Empire agriculture
flourished in the savannah increased by
the population moving south from the
Sahel
agriculture produced more grains and
cereals further increasing the
population
goats and sheep continued to graze in
the Sahel and traitors brought Cola nuts
and exotic Forest snails from the forest
lands
agricultural production and local trade
and food stuff continued to contribute
to population growth and since the Kings
taxed all agricultural products the
Royal coffers grew full
as we have also seen long distance trade
depended on luxury goods and Molly
controlled the greatest luxury of them
all gold from the gold fields of the
Niger River Valley and further south on
the Volta River
workers Pan the alluvial gold from the
rivers and though the Kings owned every
nugget Gold Dust was used for local
trade
as elsewhere this wealth was reflected
in the growth of cities important towns
like GAO wallata and niani grew up along
what became an East-West trade route
but the most important city of the Mali
Empire was Timbuktu located above the
bend in the Niger River
the northernmost point of the river
Timbuktu is located on the border
between the Sahara Desert and the Sahel
the critical point were Goods passed
between the desert berbers and the
people of the Savannah
salt gold and other Goods passed through
this city and the Kings taxed them all
Timbuktu probably had a population of
about a hundred thousand and became
famous as a center for Islamic worship
and study
it's great mosque the sunkora mosque is
the oldest mosque south of the Sahara it
was built in the 14th century and is
made of round dried mud bricks
as we will see in a later lecture
Timbuktu became a major Center of
Islamic Studies linking West Africa with
Muslims from Egypt and Beyond
the city is known for the many important
Islamic manuscripts that are preserved
today and which still draw Scholars from
around the world
Timbuktu was built and fortified in the
14th century by mali's most famous ruler
Mansa Musa he ruled Mali from 1312 until
his death in 1337 and he literally
placed Molly on the map for Europeans
and Asians during his Reign map makers
included his Empire on their maps of
Africa
how did he come to such prominence
in 1324 he performed the pilgrimage to
Mecca the Hajj that is required as one
of the pillars of Islamic faith and he
made his pilgrimage in spectacular
fashion
to reach Arabia he first crossed the
long arduous desert heading north
he took with him a huge retinue he
loaded a hundred camels each carrying
300 pounds of gold and they were guarded
with over ten thousand soldiers and 500
slaves
he was joined by his senior wife and his
main advisors
he successfully navigated the Sahara and
arrived in Cairo
when he returned from his pilgrimage
Mansa Musa brought Architects poets and
Scholars who helped contribute to
timbuktu's establishment as a center of
learning
while the world was amazed at Molly's
wealth
within his kingdom he received criticism
for spending so lavishly on his Hajj and
it took years for the kingdom to recover
Molly was not the only prosperous region
that emerged in Africa during the high
Middle Ages during the Early Middle Ages
Bantu speakers moved toward the east
coast of Africa south of the Old Kingdom
of Aksum on the Horn of Africa
these people mixed with Arab traders
from the Indian Ocean
the resulting people were known as the
Swahili which means people of the coast
in Arabic
during their Heyday from about 1200 to
1500 the Swahili created a string of
wealthy towns and cities on the 2400
Mile Stretch of Coastline between
Mogadishu and the North and Northern
Mozambique in the south
this Swahili Coast formed a second
wealthy Trading Zone in Africa
Swahili had become the major language of
East Africa today with more than 100
million speakers
these cities boasted beautiful
multi-story houses built of coral Stone
and some of the towns had populations of
up to 15 000 people
their Harbors were filled with ships
from around the Indian Ocean that took
advantage of the monsoon winds that had
brought goods to this region for
centuries
the merchants of these cities lived
comfortably in their Coral Stone houses
for which they are famous
these houses had rooms surrounding
Courtyards and a high degree of material
Comfort indoor toilets running water
rooftop Terraces and beautifully carved
wooden doors they displayed expensive
Chinese porcelain and other Rich trade
goods
these coastal cities were not simply
intermediaries between the Asian trade
and goods from the African interior such
as gold from Mali instead they profited
from a complex economy that included
fishing raising domesticated animals
boat building and other trades
one of the sources that allow us to see
the diversity of this Region's economy
comes from the account of a 14th century
traveler to Swahili Coast he writes of
the meals he was served stews of chicken
meat fish and vegetables a testimony to
its culinary diversity
he writes of bananas cooked in milk
showing that bananas that originate in
Southeast Asia had already found their
way and thrived in East Africa
he writes of food seasoned with
peppercorns from India saffron from
Spain and mangoes from Southeast Asia
the diverse world came together at the
tables of the Swahili Coast
the high point of the Middle Ages from
the 12th through the 13th century was
fostered by several factors a warming
climate
increased agricultural production and
population
and a growth of centralized governments
these influences allowed for a restored
and invigorated urban life that
facilitated trade wealth and awareness
of the greater world
coming up I will look more closely at
some of the artistic and intellectual
accomplishments of the high Middle Ages
that all this growing wealth fostered
I'll look at architecture philosophy and
literature to see the creative
outpouring of the Middle Ages all over
the world that so many of us continue to
admire today